-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show"!
You're here. You made it.
You're watching.
Thank you very much.
Well, guys, this is big.
Last night the January 6th
commission revealed that
during the Capitol riots,
the White House Chief of Staff
got texts pleading for Trump to
calm things down
from Fox News anchors
and Donald Trump Jr.
[ Audience murmurs ]
Yeah.
Trump ignored the advice of the
closest to him and also Don Jr.
[ Laughter ]
Trump was like, "If I replied to
every text that said
'What you're doing is crazy,'
I'd never get anything done."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it came out
that Fox News hosts
were begging Trump
to do something.
And today, Fox News hosts
lit their tree on fire again
just to change the subject.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Trump didn't want to hear it.
Not only did he ignore the texts
from Fox News,
he also dropped them from
his family cellphone plan.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, White House
Chief of Staff Mark Meadows was
getting texts during the attack
asking Trump to intervene.
For example, Sean Hannity
texted -- and this is real --
"Can he make a statement, ask
people to leave the Capitol?"
Yep, that's not all Meadows
received.
Several other messages that day
too.
For example, Eric Trump texted,
"Head stuck in Capitol
staircase railing.
Send help!"
[ Laughter ]
Next up, Rudy Gillian texted,
"Just showed up
at Capitol Total Landscaping.
When's the riotin' start?"
[ Laughter ]
And finally President Trump
texted Meadows,
"Just make sure they don't take
away my Twitter!"
Yeah, there you go.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Crazy day all around.
[ Applause ]
Some more news from Washington.
The White House just announced
their plan to add
500,000 charging stations
for electric vehicles
across the country.
It's incredible.
Somehow we can build half
a million charging stations,
but we can't add a second outlet
at LaGuardia.
[ Laughter ]
Can I charge my phone?
I just -- Okay.
You guys hear this?
Today, the State of New York
ordered former governor
Andrew Cuomo to return
the $5 million he received from
his book on leadership
during the pandemic.
I think it's safe
to say the drinking
at the Cuomo family
Christmas has already begun.
[ Laughter ]
Some business news -- After
announcing their name change,
Facebook paid a bank
in South Dakota
$60 million for the
rights to their new name, Meta.
It's making me emotional because
seeing a bank get $60 million
is what Christmas is all about.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
That's right, a bank.
Now they're so rich,
they don't even chain
their pens to the table anymore.
[ Laughter ]
"Just take them!
That's a Montblanc.
Just take it."
I like how Facebook
was trying to rename
their company something "cool,"
but it was already being used
by a bank in South Dakota.
[ Laughter ]
Well, this is encouraging.
I read that despite
supply chain issues,
UPS and the Postal Service
have improved their on-time
deliveries compared to
last year's holiday season.
That's right.
They now deliver
that little slip that says,
"Sorry we missed you"
right on time.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Right on time.
"Ah, I was here all day."
I saw that LG has a new
battery-powered TV that you can
wheel around on a stand
to watch anywhere.
Yeah, a TV on wheels.
It is perfect
if you've ever dreamt of being
a substitute teacher from 1997.
[ Laughter ]
And get this -- Uber Eats just
made its first-ever delivery
to space after a Japanese
billionaire brought food
from the app to astronauts on
the International Space Station.
That's how tough the economy is
right now --
a billionaire is working for
Uber Eats.
[ Laughter ]
Well, this is interesting.
A new study found that
rocket scientists
and brain surgeons
are not any smarter
than the general population.
[ Laughter ]
That's got to be a great study
to read right before
you're wheeled in
for brain surgery, right?
It's like, "Huh?"
Brain surgeons were like, "You
need to be super smart to know
about the brain and all those
little tubey things around it."
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a woman eating at
a restaurant in New Orleans
found a dozen pearls in
an oyster that she ordered.
[ Audience murmurs ]
The woman said she would
probably sell the pearls
when they passed in
six to eight hours.
Guys, we have exactly
four shows left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time for
that beloved "Tonight Show"
tradition.
It's time for "12 Days of
Christmas Sweaters."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ 12 days of
Christmas sweaters ♪
♪ Four days left ♪
-That's right.
Every show between now and
Christmas, we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
a phenomenal Christmas sweater
from the "Countdown to
Christmas" cabinet.
Now...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Since there are
four shows left --
wow -- let's open door
number four.
[ Drum roll ]
Ooh, that's right in the middle.
Go for it, bud,
whenever you're ready.
Ah! Very nice.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Beautiful.
Oh!
Wow. It lights up.
Can we dim the lights
a little bit?
I thought it lit up.
Oh, it lights up when you move?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I don't know what -- Wow.
Oh, yeah.
Alright. Alright.
Wow. It just kind of blinks
when it wants to blink.
Alright, here we go.
Let's see who's going home with
tonight's sweater, okay?
Everyone look at
your seat number.
If I call your number,
come on down.
Quest, can I get a drum roll,
please?
[ Drum roll ]
Seat number 4-3-3!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Yo!
Hey!
Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Wow.
Oh, my gosh.
This is going to be more
like a dress for you.
[ Laughter ]
What is your name?
-I'm Jessica.
-Jessica, where are you from,
Jessica?
-Colombia.
-Colombia, oh, my goodness!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Jessica, welcome to the show.
-Thank you.
-Thank you for being here.
Do you have anything like this
at home?
-No.
-Oh, my gosh.
Well, would you like to
try it on right now?
-Well, I feel so happy
to be here,
especially for this present.
I was talking with a guy before.
[ Laughter ]
They know.
-Is everything okay?
-The cold weather is crazy
for me here
because in my country it is
warm, so this is perfect.
-Try it on.
I think it'll look great on you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah. Oh, yeah. Look at this.
There's no wrong way
to wear it.
Oh, my good-- Look at this!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look at that! Come on now!
Yes!
Oh, it's so beautiful.
Congratulations.
It'll keep you warm.
Welcome. Thank you for being
here. I appreciate it.
One more time for our audience
member right there.
Stick around.
[ Cheers and applause ]
When we come back,
we're singing
a special Christmas song
with Matthew McConaughey!
Come on back!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]